[Applause]
[Music]
ethic hedge and Adila the leader of the
revolution plot out how they can steal
an artifact called the node of power
it's being used to run a heavily
fortified train that runs all around the
country providing supplies to
settlements and facilities this armored
behemoth undergoes a complex and
unpredictable unloading procedure a
procedure which is displayed in detail
on a screen within the engine car right
means the train will go one car length
forward and left means the train will go
the same distance backwards while
unloading the train frequently moves
back and forth so a typical sequence
might look like this also within the
engine car is a button that can only be
pressed once when pressed it lets down
the force field over the artifact for 10
seconds the engine car is tiny and
designed for a robot of your team only
hedge can fit the members of the
resistance have positioned a crane over
the train tracks that can pluck the
artifact once it's exposed they'll know
when to lower the crane by sight but the
only way hedge can determine the trains
position and know when to lower the
force field is by analyzing the
unloading procedure because he'll be
inside the windowless engine car
hedge can't program himself though so
it's up to ethic to tell him what to do
the artifact is in the car ten positions
behind the one that's directly under the
crane at the start what instructions can
epoch give hedge so that he hits the
button at just the right moment pause
now to figure it out for yourself
here's a hint to get you started the key
to this problem as with many programming
challenges is to reframe the information
in a way that a computer can work with a
computer doesn't know what a train is
nor does it need to it can however work
with variables try making a variable
that tracks the trains position how will
it change as the Train moves let's start
by breaking this problem into two
objectives the first is to know where
the train will be as it carries out its
instructions the second is to hit the
button when the train is in just the
right position for the first objective
it'll help to think of the Train as a
big number line let's make 0 the car
with the note 1 the car in front of it
and so on that means car 10 is under the
crane at the start when the train moves
one car right car 9 is under the crane
so a right arrow can be thought of as
subtract 1 and when the Train moves left
from there 10 is back under the crane
making a left arrow the same as ad 1
let's set our train position variable to
10 since that's where we start we can
now use a loop to read the instructions
one at a time adding or subtracting as
we go to track which car is under the
crane the nice thing about setting up
the variable this way is that it tells
us how far the note is from the crane so
as soon as the variable hits 0 hedge
should hit the button and here's what
happens
ethic gets into position on the crane
while hedge rushes off and slips into
the engine car unnoticed just before the
Train lurches to life it rolls three
cars back one forward another four back
then so far forward ethic loses track
before it reverses once more when the
artifact finally rolls into position a
deala lowers the crane hoping ethic and
hedge got it right at the last possible
moment the force field sputters and
falls ethic swoops in and lifts the node
of power to freedom when ethic gives the
node to hedge for safekeeping something
incredible happens the artifact shimmers
to life with a vision of the past when
the crystal was unearthed no one could
make the console inside work the
government put out a call for people to
try their luck with it one at a time
ethic loved to figure out what made
things tick so she signed up within
moments at the console something clicked
into place and she created her first
robot the government hired ethic as
chief robotics engineer on the spot
within a year her creations ran almost
every aspect of society and the nation
and its people thrived no longer needing
to toil in the fields and factories
[Music]
[Applause]
the vision ends and hedge detects the
second artifact in the won 9-8
forest to the southeast luckily the
Train is going there next and has just
enough reserve fuel for the trip ethic
and hedge smuggle themselves aboard and
find a hiding spot for the long journey
ahead continue the adventure in Episode
five of think like a coder or restart
the journey with episode 1 and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]